Speaker 1: This is so funny.
Donald Trump has been calling for protests
for days on the basis of his allegedly imminent
arrest and indictment.
Trump has been saying protest, protest, protest.
It is time.
It is time to take the country back, etc..
Well, protesters did show up yesterday outside
of Trump Tower, except they were protesting
in favor of Trump getting arrested.
This is just so funny.
Trump screaming to anyone that will listen.
You've got to go and protest.
There were protesters, but they had a sign
saying Trump is guilty.
No one is above the law.
Seditious conspiracy, lock Trump up, etc..
Take a look at this.
Take a listen.
Not exactly the protests Trump was looking
for.
Speaker 2: Interestingly enough, we bring
you this live shot here.
We know the former president has called for
four protests in a peaceful manner.
Many Republicans push back on that.
But interestingly enough, it's the opposite
side that's outside protesting now saying
insurrection, tick tock, time's up.
No one is above the law.
Trump is guilty.
Speaker 1: Sir.
The protesters are here.
Fantastic.
What are the signs?
Say, sir?
They say to lock you up.
Speaker 2: And many supporting the possible
indictment of former President Trump.
There again, the.
Speaker 1: Signs really look like they were
made by the grass roots.
Grass roots groups do, don't they, John?
Speaker 2: Yeah, we'll continue to follow
that again.
Speaker 1: And so this is a report from Newsmax,
by the way, the guest here suggesting the
signs that are being held up are too professionally
made to really be actual activists grassroots
sign.
Clearly there is someone behind it, and usually
the someone is George Soros.
I mean, you have to understand the language.
That's a dog whistle if I've ever seen one.
Not exactly the protest that Donald Trump
was looking for.
One more thing on protests, a group did.
Gather in Florida yesterday outside of Mar
a Lago, and this was in West Palm Beach.
This is really funny.
MSNBC interviewed a Trump supporter who was
at the protest and she says, we are not protesting.
We're not.
And by the way, if Trump's indicted, we're
not going to do anything seemingly wanting
to preempt any possibility of Trumpists being
accused of violence.
She seems not to be liking this narrative
of where we are here, Chris.
I want to just introduce you real fast to
one woman who we met.
Debbie, you were telling me that you helped
look this online.
What type of folks have you done this before?
Have you had you tried to get people out and
come out here before?
Speaker 3: I just have a group of friends
and we are made and just get it out to some
and they get it out to some.
And that's just how.
Speaker 1: When you saw Donald Trump call
for a protest, what did that mean to you?
Protest.
Speaker 3: We're not protesting.
We're supporting the person president.
Speaker 1: Not protest.
And if he were to be invited, what should
the response be from supporters like you?
Speaker 3: Nothing.
But just have a big party and laugh it off.
Speaker 1: That's the best.
Well, if so, what would people like you do?
Nothing.
We would celebrate the arrest.
Speaker 3: It's ridiculous.
Speaker 1: Whichever folks are here today.
Speaker 3: Everyday, normal, everyday, hardworking
people.
Speaker 1: There you go.
Obviously very hardworking enough to be out
protesting at 1:09 p.m. on a Tuesday.
As we know, that's notoriously a time when
hard working people are able to go and just
hold flags for a guy who lost a recent election
and simply can't accept that.
So this is going to be super interesting.
But I maintain right now when I take the temperature
of MAGA, I don't get the definitive feeling
that they're ready to go and riot if and when
Trump is arrested.
And I think that's a good thing.
You know, a lot of right wingers write in
all the time and they say, David, you want
in order to get ratings and clicks, you want
there to be violence and that will allow you
to go after Trump supporters as being violent.
And that's you.
It's terrible that you want that.
No, no, no.
I don't want that.
I don't want that at all.
And in fact, if you go back to the January
six, 2021 Trump Trump livestream that we did
you see that?
I don't exactly look thrilled when they breach
the Capitol and break in, despite the fact
that it did generate a lot of attention.
I would rather what's better for the country,
which is for there not to be violent outbursts
as a result of the justice system carrying
forward and indicting when there is evidence
to do so.
That's not an action that I want to see there
be violence in response to.
So of course, we will be watching it.
Latest rumor is maybe indictment today, but
Trump surrender next week or maybe nothing
will happen.
We really don't know.
But as soon as I know anything, you will as
well.
Make sure you're subscribed to the David Pakman
Show YouTube channel at YouTube.com slash
The David Pakman Show.
We have a packed program for you today and
I'm glad
you're here.